everyone has a story and that story is
filled with chapters that have made us
who we are today
those early chapters of that story
sometimes are the ones that define us
the most the Center for Disease Control
has estimated that over half of our
nation's children have experienced at
least one or two types of childhood
trauma that adversity can have lasting
effects when I began to have
opportunities to speak and advocate for
students and for teachers
I found myself uniquely positioned to be
able to speak about childhood trauma but
I had to make a decision first how to
decide did I wanted to share the bright
and shiny parts of my life
you know those ones that we put out on
social media that makes us all look
perfect or did I wanted to make myself
vulnerable and become an open book the
choice became very clear in order to
make a difference in the life of a child
I had to become transparent so I made
the commitment to tell my personal story
and this story is filled with people
that have loved me and taken care of me
and grown me and have helped me overcome
and heal and now it's time for me to
help others do the same when I first
started school I was the picture of
normalcy I was from a good family
I was always dressed nicely had a smile
on my face I was prepared for school but
my life was anything but normal
by this time
I had already become a victim of sexual
abuse and it was still happening
my parents didn't know and I had not
told anyone else when I started school I
felt like this was going to be my safe
place so I was excited imagine my dismay
when I met my teacher mr. Randolph
now mr. Randolph was not my abuser but
mr. Randolph was a epitome of everything
that scared me the most in my life I had
already started these self preservation
techniques to where I took myself out of
positions where I was going to be alone
with a man and here I was as a student I
was going to be in a classroom with a
man every day for a year of school I was
scared I didn't trust him but you know
what mr. Randolph would turn out to be
my greatest advocate but in the
beginning oh I made sure he knew I did
not like him
I was non-compliant I was that kid that
was disengaged and I also made it really
hard on my parents too
I didn't want to go to school so I
fought them every morning getting on the
bus at night I couldn't sleep because my
anxiety was so high so I was going into
class exhausted which exhausted children
or cranky children and they're not easy
to teach you know that mr. Randolph
could have approached me with
frustration like so many teachers do
with students like me but not him he
approached me with empathy and with
flexibility I was so grateful for that
he saw the six-year-old was tired and
weary and so instead of making me go
outside for recess he would let me stay
in and take naps because he knew I
needed rest instead of sitting at the
teacher table at lunch he would come and
sit with the students at the student
table he would engage me and all of my
classmates in conversation and I now
look back and I know he had a purpose
for that he was listening he was asking
questions he needed to find out what was
going on he built a relationship with me
he earned my trust and slowly but surely
those walls that I had built around
myself
he started chipping away at and I
eventually realized he was one of the
good guys I know that he felt like he
wasn't enough because he made the move
to talk to my mom and got my mom's
permission to let me start seeing with
school guidance counselor mrs. McFadden
I started seeing miss McFadden once or
twice a week for the next two years it
was a process during that time period I
never disclosed to her the abuse because
it was a secret wasn't supposed to tell
but she connected the dots I know she
did because everything that she did with
me was to empower me and help me find my
voice she taught me how to use mental
images to push through my fears she
taught me breathing techniques to help
me get through those anxiety attacks
that I would have so often and she will
played with me and she made sure that I
could stand up for myself in situations
and the day came where I was in a room
with my abuser and one other adults and
I told my truth
I told about the abuse immediately my
abuser began to deny and the person that
is close to they just weren't equipped
to handle the bombshell that I just
dropped on them it was easier to believe
the abuser rather than a child so I was
told never to speak of it again
I was made to feel like I had done
something wrong again
it was devastating but you know what
something good came out of that day my
abuser knew that I was no longer going
to be silent the power shifted and the
abuse stopped
but the shame and fear of a being again
remained and it would remain with me for
many many years to come mr. Randolph and
miss McFadden they helped me find my
voice they helped me find the way out
but you know what there are so many kids
that aren't as fortunate as me and you
have them in your classrooms that is why
it's so important for me to talk to you
today so you can be aware and you can
start asking the questions that need to
be asked and paying attention to these
students so you too can help them find
their way as a kindergarten teacher I
start my year off with my kids making
box biographies these are two of my
students and I encourage them to fill
those boxes with things that tell me
about them and about their life what's
important to you you know they decorate
them and I mean they really take time
they fill them with pictures of their
families and of their pets and and then
I let them present them to me into the
class and during that time I'm an active
listener because the things they say the
facial expressions that they give me the
things they don't say can become red
flags for me and can help me figure out
what their needs are what is driving
them to maybe have the behaviors that
they're showing me in class how can I be
a better teacher by listening to their
voices I also make times to develop
relationships with them much like mr.
Randolph did with me a sit with them at
lunch I have conversations with them
only at recess I go
they're gangs on the weekends I go to
their dance recitals I become a part of
their life because in order to really
know a student you've got to infuse
yourself into their lives now I know
some of you are middle school teachers
and high school teachers and you might
think that those kids have already kind
of developed and and you know they're on
autopilot at that point but don't be
deceived especially the kids that you
think have it all together because those
are the ones that might need you the
most if you were to look at my yearbook
you would see me on about every page
because I was involved in everything I
even drove a school bus so I was that
kid that teachers thought was the
overachiever the popular person the one
that had it together but guys I was lost
I lost and I wanted someone to ask me
listen why are you here all the time why
are you throwing yourself into all these
things
did they ever wonder was I running away
from someone was I running away from
something why did I not want to be in my
community right in my home why did I
want to be at school all the time no one
ever asked now don't get me wrong all
overachievers in your schools are not
victims of abuse or trauma but I just
want you to take the time to be curious
ask them why you may find out that there
is a reason behind it you could be the
reason that they move forward with their
story be careful not to assume that you
already know the ending to their story
don't put a period where a semicolon
should be keep that story going and help
them know that even
if something has happened traumatic to
them that their life is still worth
telling their story is worth telling now
in order to do that I really feel like
we have to embrace our own personal
stories as educators many of you might
be sitting there and thinking yeah that
happened to me but I'm not ready to
share and that's okay
the time will come when you will feel it
inside your soul that it's time to turn
your past pain into purpose for the
future these children are our future I
just encourage you to take it day-by-day
talk to someone be willing and just open
my life story came full circle in the
spring of 2018 where I was invited to
speak to a group of beginning teachers
and mentors I shared my story much like
today with you and afterwards I had a
lady approached me she had tears in her
eyes and she quietly said thank you
thank you for sharing I cannot wait to
tell my dad everything that I heard
today she must have seen the perplexed
look on my face because she followed up
by saying mr. Randolph is my dad and he
often wonders did he make a difference
today I get to go home and tell him you
definitely made a difference what a gift
what a gift and that prompted me to
reach out to miss McFadden's daughter as
well and to share with her what an
impact mrs. McFadden had made and I
wanted her to know I have
kated for more funding for guidance
counselor's for school social workers
for psychologists for nurses because
they are so vital to the mental and
physical health of our children I'm
thankful for miss McFadden I once heard
someone say in order to find your way
out of the darkness you have to find the
light today I hope that you leave this
place and you seek opportunities to be
the light for not only students but for
adults in your your classrooms in your
schools in your communities you have the
gift to help someone navigate through
their trauma and make their story worth
telling thank you
[Applause]